two decades on from the original launch
of the shahram volkswagen has given the
second generation a little makeover its
trademark quality such as the flexible
interior concept ride comfort and safety
are still on board
plus a couple of new goodies that's
official Sharan has sold around 800,000
units since 1995 explains our car
reviewer Klaus it's a real family car
and was in fact originally twinned with
a Sayeda humba and the Ford Galaxie this
latest version of the second generation
is very similar to the outgoing model
there are minimal changes on the outside
but more significant ones under the hood
and in the cabin the design of the
seven-seater MPV is more or less the
same among the new editions bolder front
lamps and LED lights at the rear
as always the sliding doors mean easy
access for passengers
the interior boasts classic VW hallmarks
the layout absolutely driver friendly
the Chiron boasts a wide range of
storage options literally all over the
cabin the variable seating concept has
likewise been retained the standard
cargo volume is 822 litres with the
seats down rising to almost 2300 liters
the Chiron is no lightweight points out
Klaus it weighs in at one point seven
tons so if you then load it fully you
might find it tilts a little around
bends but it's always safe the 2-liter
TDI version we tested generates 85
kilowatts and has a top speed of 184
km/h the NPV can make the dash to 100
km/h and twelve point six seconds
official fuel consumption is 5.1 liters
per 100 kilometers with co2 emissions of
132 grams per kilometer the magic word
these days has Klaus is connectivity and
this Chiron meets the requirements you
can plug in your smart phone to this
multimedia system allowing you to view
your phone display on the monitor
while your phone is connected to the
system you can call up the most
important functions on the color TFT
display you can browse through your
archive of music tracks for example and
pick one to play via the touchscreen the
Sharan also scores on the driver assist
front with an array of features safety
is a big priority with the vehicles
makers explains Klaus which is why it
has a collection of electronic assist
unmatched in its class
there's the multi-collision brake or the
rear traffic alert system where the
monitor warns the driver of passing
vehicles while exiting a parking space
open each team on sofa difficult for the
first time the Saran has been fitted
with adaptive cruise control a further
boost to safety when driving down
highways or on longer journeys
the guns Klaus has saved the really
positive aspect until last the new
edition costs no more than its
predecessor 32,000 euros for the base
model which comes with a gasoline engine
that diesel equivalent costs just under
thirty three and a half thousand they
say never change a winning team and
that's certainly true with the VW Sharan